[Music]
hey
and last the welcome wagon has arrived
ted lasso said lesson head lasso head
lasso ted lasso
is an injection of goodness
i'm fine the level of thanks that comes
across social media
imagine getting tweets from people
saying we are kinder to each other in
our family
because you've reminded us that that's
what we should all be it's a choice in
it to be positive and grateful and i now
find myself
saying i appreciate you to most people
after an interaction this is why it's
hard to love you
oh he loves you the positivity that
people have felt
about the show and talking about the
kind of lasso way being
very funny but also very human it's
undeniable keep an eye on these guys
because around the 74 minute mark
there's gonna be a room full of grown
man crying
i'll be one of them every man woman is
living a comedy
a drama and a tragedy and the messages
reflect that notion
speaking with people and the fans and
the reactions changed
my life i was walking and randomly a
person just
started screaming football is life
football is like
someone who messaged me on twitter said
their 11 year old son
missed a shot that would have tied the
game and she's like right now you're
upset but
what do we need to do and he goes be a
goldfish like sam
you remember what animal has the
shortest memory for goldfish
what do you think we should all do once
we get done being sad
i think we should all be a goldfish i
brought you a little something oh yeah
cookies or as you all call them here
biscuits
getting a lot of biscuit recipes people
going oh look at these that we made or
little videos of them going oh my god
they taste as good as yours and who knew
that that whole biscuits with the boss
thing would go so nuts
[Music]
i forgive you why
divorce is hard it makes folks do crazy
things
some of the more profound responses that
have reached me personally have been
from people going through things that
characters have gone through on the show
or just something that's really taken
hope out of their hearts and
how the show moved them in a way that
refilled their love cup so to speak
oh it feels good to laugh and season two
is
even better
[Music]
season two stays as adorable as the
first
how long was i doesn't matter you're
back now let's do this
you listen to me coach lasso we have
work to do
next season
you